quarter commercial three in the fourth
oh we got the match oh here's your
matchup here's your matchup
the two Celtics how many times have they
played King of the court in Boston right
had a little fade away
okay gotta go back you gotta go right
back here we go oh and then he gave him
a too small he gave him a too small
[Applause]
[Music]
that's
nice but you got to be able to finish it
though right
we're gonna come back for some more and
then again come back for some more
remember it was tannable broke
Brown's face that facial fracture
Friendly Fire
for three
two little too little
yes
[Applause]
but Missoula has to be smiling these are
two of his stars that are on the same
team you know Missoula said Jason do not
touch Jalen brown right now trying to
get him back at healthy another round
they go
[Applause]
yeah I like it potato with 42 he had 25
in the corner but the memories will be
those two matching up against one
another
here's the thing they're problems and
they play for the same team but tonight
Opposites Attract there's a little Fade
Away by Brown and then the step back
three
for Jalen Brown and then Jason Tatum
says yeah hold up hold up hold up hold
my beer yeah hold my beer I can knock it
down from Beyond The Ark talking a
little mess got the crowd involved
that's everything we wanted in all-star
weekend
[Music]
[Applause]